let me
well so i am going to start
now this is a
webinar
on
benefits he uses
the advantages of a six sigma program in
industry
so i just want to ask a question is
has anybody heard of six sigma is
anybody familiar with six sigma
amanda kathleen
i'm not
yes i've heard
so let me
i'm going to assume that
you want to know
what this program is about
and then you can assess yourself and you
can ask questions i think a little more
much better thing to do
so let me just move on to the next slide
here i'm trying to
okay there it is
so my name is shree gupta
i am a certified black belt
and i used to work for motorola before i
retired late last year
and that was my main job
in motorola
to work as a black belt as a six sigma
expert
so i would be called in
whenever there were problems
big problems i was working in
engineering development team
so this team used to develop create what
are called the two-way videos
so if you've seen the policeman
firemen when they go around they have
these big heavy radios the bigger
overblown sized cell phones
with them
so those are the ones that were designed
in our facility here in
near miami in fort lauderdale florida
so it is very very important
that we create the products
with the right quality
right reliability and the right cost
so that is where my expertise would come
in
to make sure the engineers worked
at a high level of productivity they
don't really waste time and you see some
examples later on
what we mean
and that
we economize everywhere
without compromising quality
so saving dollars without compromising
quality in fact giving a better quality
a lot of time if you do it correctly
you can provide better quality product
at a lower cost
that is what industry is about
all right
so please i will repeat
if you have any questions
please talk me
and
holler
so this this this seminar will go 45
minutes to an hour
[Music]
in your organization
some examples and of course
the example really will be distributed
throughout the presentation
and then when you have a six sigma
program in an organization
what are the roles of responsibility
what kind of individuals are put in
place to make this program a success
and
for you particularly as participants
what is in there for you what does what
value does it bring to you individually
as a sixth
sigma professional
so i'm assuming that most of the people
who are participating
have not gone through any formal
six sigma results of natural education
so we have a program simply learn we
have a program where you can be
certified
at different levels of six sigma
expertise
and in general these are called green
bells and black similar to florata you
have different
grades
of
skills
so of course we are not going to depth
of these tools
so this is just before
for you to familiarize with you
and you hope you think that this will
bring some excitement in you it will
motivate you to
go for your certification
if you're going to certify it
you have a much wider
options to where you can work and apply
these
skills
so these six sigma skills
are independent of the kind of industry
so if you go to the hospital you'll find
six sigma experts six more programs you
go to banks you'll find
six sigma programs
you go to service industry like hotels
and
now you'll find six sigma programs
you could go to manufacturing you'll
find these six sigma programs you go to
police forces
so safety forces safety organizations
you'll find six or six sigma programs so
six sigma programs are
everywhere and they have caught on
pretty well so once you have six sigma
skills
then you have many more options open in
front of you
to find the kind of jobs that interest
you right
any questions so far
so i'm going to go in to a brief
introduction
into six sigma
so always i when you are coming you hear
this word six sigma what the hell is it
what what is six sigma
so really six sigma is a quality process
and it's a very it provides you
a proper structure of framework
to deliver
almost perfect or very
products which are very close to
perfection
and
the definition of perfection really is
it doesn't have defects it doesn't fail
so give an example
i
buy a cell phone
so buy a cell phone
i turn it on
i expect it to work as soon as i turn it
on expect to turn on it should show me
all the menus and when i want to make a
phone call you should make a phone call
and i want to talk for half an hour or
one hour
i should continue talking for an hour
without the call dropping
so if the call drops in between there's
a failure there's a defect
so when i'm using the phone
it should not fall apart
so the product
has to work
it should be available for me to use all
the time
so that is what is perfection
so in the six sigma is very structured
methodology
to create
very high quality products and services
and there's a
series of tools within a six sigma
program
that the six sigma professionals are
exposed to
they acquire skill in it they become
professionals
they apply these tools
to achieve this
goal
to make defect free product or service
so whatever
you do you manufacture a cellular phone
you design a cell phone
you design a hotel
you design a bridge
you design a road you make a road
whatever you do
there should be no defect in this when
you make a road there should be no bumps
in it
when you create a bridge
it should be very even
it should not vibrate it should not
oscillate so all those kind of things
there should be no defects
okay
and just think
if you're manufacturing a million
cellular phones for example
and some phones are defective
and on the defective you have to throw
them away so that's the money you lost
so you make a million phones
and let's say you have
10 000 phones which have defects in them
so you have lost revenue equivalent to
cost of 10 000 phones let's say you
it costs you dollars each
so you've lost like a million dollars
with the ten thousand problems
so
that is very very important you do not
want to scrap anything
so really
six sigma is a process
so why is it called six sigma so that's
the other question and this is what is
answered here what is it called six
sigma why is it not called one sigma two
sigma
so six
in a statistical terminology sigma
is
a measure of variation
anyway so i'll give an example
if you measure the height of
let's say adult population united states
similarly high night varies so some
people
can be four feet few inches some are
about five some about six sometimes go
to seven
feet
so you measure the height
so you'll find a distribution
so there's a variation in height
so sigma is the measure of that
variation
so
larger the sigma so the more the sigmas
that you have
the more variation you're going to take
care of in your process right and any
variation of the defect right
so give an example
of a variation somewhere so let's say
the cell phone
is the color of the cell phone is
blue exactly blue
so some cell phones that you make
are not exactly blue they are navy blue
they have different shades of blue those
are defects
so you don't want those that very very
very
creation is a defect right so you go
away from blue standard blue it's a
defect
so if you look at the defects
so this is this the first column in the
statement shows you the sigma level and
the
second column shows what is called the
defects per million opportunities but
very simple i'll break it down to simple
terms
so if i produce a million cell phones
how many of these cell phones are
defective
it depends on what sigma level on your
map
so if i am only at one sigma which is a
basic quality level very very basic
level
out of a million cycle phones that i
produce
i'm likely to have almost 700 000
defective
if i am at five sigma level
i'm likely to have about 233
cell phones defective and if i go to 6 i
will have only 3.4 defective out of a
million units
so it is a tremendous
saving look at the difference it makes
as you go higher deeper
six sigma level
so you can also think of for example if
you have a very high safety and
reliability industry
like aerospace
[Music]
progresses and this how did
the turn six sigma was created for the
most of the industry
is a very good number
so you imagine remember
the higher the sigma level you go the
cost of maintaining that signal sigma
level also goes up
so it's a cost benefit ratio
how much are you willing to pay for
so let me explain it a little bit more
but just
any questions so far is everywhere is
everybody okay with what i have said so
far
all right
so moving on
so give an example there's a restaurant
and they deliver some sandwiches
and the target is that it should be
delivered within 30 minutes all the subs
should be delivered within 30 minutes
so now
i take i keep the data so each delivery
i log it in a register on a spreadsheet
and after a month i take an average and
i find an average of 24 minutes
so my average delivery time is 24
minutes
right and my target is
that
all the subs should be delivered in less
than 30 minutes
so i have a question for the team
and please speak up
and mute your phone
your
computers and then your microphones and
then speak up
do you think
that
all the customers were happy
with this restaurant where the average
delivery time was 24 minutes
do you think the restaurant did very
well
any answers
come on somebody should
i i don't hear anybody
hi this is kathleen i think the
restaurants with uh the customers are
pleased but i think that the time could
be improved
okay thanks kathleen for speaking out
well so here let's let me show this
right
so average
maybe a misleading
metric
so i'm trying to move to the next okay
so this is
and that's what i've shown in the next
chart here
so you see the distribution the
horizontal line is the delivery time
and the word
and this charge here is already
did somebody say anything
okay okay
well so please please
if you want
i think some phones are
muted
so microphones are here
is
not muted
so this curve shows
for each of the delivery times
how many customers saw the delivery time
so this one here for example 10 minute
delivery time which is excellent
was seen by
if i draw a vertical line here so many
customers and i don't have the numbers
here let's assume that there's five
customers
20 minutes
was seen by 20 customers 24 minutes just
the average was seen by maybe 30
customers
so and so forth so if you see 30 minutes
was seen by
about 20 or so customers
but they were also customers which saw
more than 30 minutes
so this is how the distribution is
so if i add all of them up and take an
average i get an average 24 minutes
which is better than 30 minute target
but
you see this blue area all this
the customer saw more than 30 minutes
so guess what i didn't meet the target
in this area so so many customers saw
more than 30 men
so this is how
we work in six sigma
we understand what the average means
and we understand what customer
satisfaction
means none of the customers saw 30
minutes or higher
so of course you'll have unhappy
customers and this customer might go to
other restaurants and
then i can lose them
so if i don't handle it correctly i i
could lose and i will not understand my
average is so good is 24 is 30 and still
i i'm losing customers
so that is example of six sigma here
okay so i want to move
on
some reason my computer is a bit slow
there it is
so there's another example here
and you see the same kind of chart
there's two charts so one month you have
the black line
and another one is dashed
red line
so these are different distributions
and obviously you'll see the red one so
this one is much better than this black
line month
so as soon as i draw it i can compare it
so i can see the average
is lower the average is 60 something and
here the average is about 105 or
something
plus the variation here is much narrower
you see the minimum to maximum
here is from 0 to 100
in the black line the minimum from 0 to
150 almost
so the variation in that is too much
also
so this black this process is not good
so i have some i make an improvement
so here how the story works
so initially my process
was for following this black line
and i found because i'm losing customers
my business is not doing well
i draw this chart i see the problem then
i do something make improvements and i
get this red chart
so when i get to this red curve
my data and i see i get more more
customer more business the process
improved and of course if you have much
better process you'll have better
customer satisfaction
okay
are you with me
some more examples of six sigma
so if you have three sigma level versus
six sigma levels the real life things
so in a country
if it is working if the airports are
working at three sigma level
they're likely to have around 964 flight
cancels
in a day
however if it is a six sigma level
only one flight in three weeks rather
than a single day
is likely to be canceled
a big difference
same thing if
babies are dropped
in the region
about 5400 babies are dropped each year
in the three sigma level
at six sigma level there will be only
one drop in four years
a huge difference
and look at the phone calls so if we had
47 three sigma level you're likely to
have 47 283 of course that's an
assumption behind this 47 283 overseas
calls
disconnected
in an hour
but at six my level
it would take more than two years to see
the same number of calls drop
so from one hour to two years
such a huge difference
so that is why and and depending on your
needs this is the investment you make
to bring it your process
your in
history your business to a six sigma
level
quality
started growing after the industrial
revolution of course the things were
very basic in the earlier industrial
revolution mostly in europe
then as the industry grew and came to
1930s
when this spc is something called
statistical process control
introduced
and people started coming up with new
methods of improving the quality
and different names
quality circles iso 9000
baldrige award which is the u.s based
award welcome ball to the world
benchmarking school card ringing and
there's different names
again i mean if you're interested you
can go through
these things and you'll find a lot of
information on the internet for each one
of these
so since sigma's part of quantities i
went through the very brief birthday
view of the quality and now into six
sigma history of six sigma
so six sigma as a concept was initiated
by motorola
back in the 80s
86 to be more precise of the guy they
introduced concept
and this was mainly driven by men
manufacturing so the amount of scrap
being created in manufacturing you know
amount of
rework being done so rework is
you make a part and there's a defect so
you can perhaps repair it so you have to
hire
some people who will do extra work to
remove the defect and sometimes you
cannot remove the defects you have to
scrap the card
so either way you lose money when you
rework you're losing money and you scrap
you lose money so this is what
so this is how it started and you've
seen earlier if you're working at one
sigma or three sigma level there's a
high number of rejects defects that are
created
it
was to remove those rejects and these
facts that this process was initiated
and became very successful it was
it was
in industry it was a very very
highly appreciated news about the
introduction of six sigma
then general electric
in the top jack welcome general electric
picked it up and he's and he applied in
manufacturing and he said no i don't
want to limit it to manufacturing i want
to apply to my other areas of business
so he applied it to his engineering and
development teams a product service
everywhere and he was highly successful
and then many other companies are like
signal and then many more companies and
there's a
you go into fortune 500 and they're very
difficult to find a company which does
not apply or use six sigma
principles right and you can see the
saving the amount of saving that each of
the company has affected
using six sigma
programs
right billions of businesses are of
course i've worked with what i've got in
industries and i've seen it myself
and the project that i've worked in
we've saved
hundreds and thousands and millions and
this is how it works
right
okay so what is within six sigma
what does six sigma program contain
again this is a bird's eye view and if
you want to go into depth you probably
have to register for some of the
assembly line courses
and simply learn hairs for each of each
one of these
appropriate courses for certification or
for general learning
so there are three
processes
in six sigma the three different
branches
many more but in general high level
these are three branches one is called
the make
the maic then we call dfsr designed for
six sigma
and the third is lean
and i'll go i'll explain a little bit
more for each one of them
the first is out of this three the first
they make so what is the make and it's a
very strange name very strange term
so this is an acronym the emaic acronym
and you expand it it's in the circle
here b
define measure analyze improve control
you take the first letter and that's the
make
so this is how it is done you define
a project
or a problem
you define it
so you understand that and i get an
example i mean
i start making a new cellular phone i
ship it to customers and lo and behold i
have a high failure rate i get 10 of the
four
of the
phones failing in the field and customer
hands
so i define a problem my problem is 10
failure rate of phones in customer hands
and i also define
a team
that will help me work on this so i get
the right experts that will help me work
on it so i'm a black belt
and i get
a mechanical engineer electrical
engineer a software engineer etc put a
team together to help me find the
problem
then the next phase i go is once the
team is formed is a measure so i create
a
bench line
it's a benchmark i'll create my baseline
data so 10 what kind of phones where do
they fail only in the northern united
states
worldwide so i gather all my data so
that's called the measurements i measure
where i am at
then i do the analysis which is called
the root cause analysis i try to find
why are these 10 percent failing what
has happened
is it because my software was defective
is it because their customers have not
been trained enough and they make
mistakes in using a phone
is it my supplier supply
i need a very poor quality of displays
or keyboards or keypads
so i find the root cause that's the
analyze phase
then the two phase once i found the root
cause then i go and fix it so it's a
software defect so i get the software
teams
they look at the defect they work on it
they fix the defect and send out the
updated software package to all the
customers control phase
is the learning phase what have i
learned from the problem from the issue
and i make sure that future it does not
happen at the end so this is the demand
for each phase the specific statistical
tools that are used
i will give you a first idea of some of
these
tools as well later on
so that is the domain process
the next one
dfss designed for six sigma
so this remake is used really when you
want to improve something which is the
manufacturing
so field failure i want to improve the
field failure rate so i apply the domain
process
in manufacturing my defect rate is very
high
so my scrap rate is very high my reverb
rate is very high and i apply my demate
growth
says
to improve those weights
dfss is totally different
this is when i'm designing a new product
so there's no question of any defect in
it
but i want to create a new product
which has no defects in it so when i
ship it
it can be manufactured very easily and
when the customer
uses it it doesn't see any defects in it
so that is the dfa design for six sigma
so you can apply it for a product or a
service
okay
so this is how this was designed the six
segment
is everybody okay so far any questions
comments
so the third
six sigma is the lean
lean is of course very simple concept
but this is where you
so whenever you're doing something
there's always some non-value added
activity
some waste
right so you just want to stock
eliminate
those non-value-added activities and the
waste
a good example when you go to a grocery
store
in the supermarket
and i've seen that person i mean if you
go to walmart or something and sometimes
you have a long line at the checkout
counter
you're waiting there so that waiting
time is a waste it's not only for you
but also for the retailer it's a problem
because if you're waiting for 20 minutes
if he had more efficient checkout
process he could have checked on many
more customers because some customer
might just walk away because waiting
time is too long
so element
needing waste
so another example how the lean concept
works and the six sigma process works
so imagine this is from a welding
technician
so he's welding some parts
and he notices
that some parts that come in that he has
to weld have rust
and what happens is that this rust you
can unweld them properly
you have to remove the rust
happened is that there should have been
no rust in the first place
right
so perhaps the rest was because the park
came in about a month ago and was lying
in my inventory in my warehouse
and my warehouse had high humidity so it
was rusting
i'm rusting
so i can do a couple of things
i
can buy the parts maybe a week in
advance rather than a month in advance
or i can change the environment the
warehouse so it doesn't rust
and i can save all the cost of this
traditional solution
right
so this is how this
so this is another example of how this
process works six sigma process works
okay
so the lean and this is really a lot of
these concepts came from japan
and you'll see a lot of japanese terms
so non-value-added activities
is really three
three ways some non-welding adding work
is really the example that i've given
you previously
also like waiting time
unevenness or burden
again this is again a very high level
view for you
when you attend the course you'll go
much more into depth of some of these
concepts
you'll appreciate much more
all right so those were the three again
the three
let me just go back here the three
six sigma methodologies very very
important we make
the maic process
where you improve
the
quality of the product
or
process or service so that is the demand
process
secondly is the dsl designed for six
sigma
here you create
a defect free product right
from scratch or a service
and the third is the lean concept
where you eliminate waste and just
general terms eliminate waste
so these are the main three main
branches of six sigma
and each one has its own tools
and literally there are hundreds of
tools but there's some tools that are
used much more often and will we'll see
a few tools here in this presentation
so in the six sigma program
the most important thing is
the program has to be accepted by the
management
it has to be driven top down
so the top exam so this is how the teams
work
so the top executives drive it down
so top executives are convinced
that the six sigma will bring in value
to the organization
they introduce the program through
champions again these are senior people
they appoint champions
and the champions make sure
that the
master of blackboard is the highest
level of six sigma certification that
master blackwell side plays
and each master black
over c is a bunch of black belts and
each black belt
works together with
a bunch of what are called green valves
so this is how the whole responsibility
works and you could have different
reporting
reporting matrices
and different organizations a lot
differently
but essentially these are the roles that
you need top executives champions
master black bells black males and green
bells
in a program
okay everybody with me so far any
questions
so what are some of the tools when you
see
a lot of acronyms here
and i'll show you how
you know in the next few slides
so now the domain d m a i say in the
image process so each of the phases
there are different tools that are used
so there is
cipher voc voc stands for voice of the
customer and that's exactly what it is
what does the customer want what are
customer requirement this is the voc
there's a fmea here lower down which is
a failure mode and effects analysis
which is failure modes
so really this is a tool to
anticipate
what can
go wrong in my manufacturing or in my
design
again i'm not going to detail a lot of
them it will take several hours if i
want to go through them but again if you
decide to do the course you'll get
exposed to most of these
in the measure there's different kind of
charts
there's a gauge studies that are done
gauges measurement system studies that
are done
cp cpk these are capability studies that
in the analyze phase slr and we have an
example slide later on is the
regression analysis called
this very interesting thing very
interesting it's called the fishbone
diagram you'll see one of them is called
the cause and effect diagram
there's some tools that you probably
have heard in proof phase like
brainstorming etc
that you probably know
they use
used widely
and there are control charts control
plans etc so there's several tools that
are used
and of course there are many more tools
that are not put down here these are
some of the main ones
okay so
in remember that
among three demand dfss and lean the fss
has a very important tool it is called
the
quality function deployment or the house
of quality better known as the house of
quality
house of quality is really
conversion of customer requirement
customer wants customer needs
into engineering language so whatever
the engineers work with engineers work
with totally different kind of words and
concepts
right
so give an example
a customer says
and this is the customer office seller
phone
so customer says the phone should be
very light it should fit in my pocket
the phone should not drop a call
but engineer is not good enough it
should be very light so what does it
mean so for engineer the phone should be
less than
two ounces
so that's what makes sense to engineer
phones should fit in in my pocket
so again definition so phone should not
be larger than three inches by six
inches something like that
so the new language language is in
inches
ounces pounds etc
for customer it is an experience
lightness
fits somewhere
so this is what the house of quality
this is what we do
right there's an example how this works
but i'm not going to go into this so on
one side we put down what does the
customer want
and this is how does a engineer
an engineer
design the product
all right
moving on another tool
so that was the house of quality
of qft
this is the cause and effect diagram
it's also called a fish bone diagram
and there's another name from the
inventor of this diagram is called
ishikawa japanese name ishikawa he's the
gentleman who
created this the first time
so it's very simple
you're trying to find out all possible
causes
of some defect or some issue that you
have seen
so here this example
is an organization is producing software
applications
and they find a problem
they find that in spite of all the
testing of the software
inspection and testing that they do in
spite of it some defects leak into the
production
and of course they get into the customer
hands
so the engines sit down and they create
this diagram so what they've done is
defect leakage into production that is
the issue so that's the effect that's
going on so what are the possible causes
and you can see it looks like a fish
gone
so it is divided into these
it could be their skill set
it could be the knowledge set
it could be
the other thing it could be
ineffective reviews that happen
in complete test case etc so this is how
this is created once this is created you
know these are all the
possible causes and then you go
into
one by one and through your testing
you eliminate each one of them and then
then you focus on the main ones
again if you decide to do the course
then you will get more exposure into
this and no practice into this
so that was the second tool which was
the
fish diagram
the another tool is called a scatter
plot
so you've got two variables against each
other
so here is an example
again it's a hypothetical example
so operations revenue
versus the number of employees
so is there any relationship between the
two
if i hire more people is my revenue
going to go up right i want to decide
i determine that
so we take the data
so take one two three four five data
points
you put in this block so when i had 100
employees my revenue was this
when i had earned
60 employees my revenue was 350 and i
put these points
and i see oh yeah it looks like there's
a trend here
and of course the software the excel
mostly sorry
mostly the excel that's what we use in
this
and you can excel ask excel to go out
what's called the regression line among
this
and what excel does is it draws a line
and people who have done the linear
maths best
it even gives an equation for this lines
is y which is the vertical axis equal to
four five seven two x
uh minus thirty three point four one
eight
is it minus that times three plus
anyway
so it gives you an equation here
so once your equation you can project it
further so if i have 200 employees
what is the revenue i can expect
from the way my company works
so you can predict
and you can use a justification to hire
more people so if i have more money if i
can borrow money
or gets from the investors
and you assure them this
curve this graph
it might be easier to convince them
so
there's different ways you can use these
tools once you know the purpose you know
ratio
you would
go and gather the data and create the
chart
okay do the analysis
so this is
how the six sigma works
again
you can go much more into depth of six
sigma
when you attend a course
right
so we have i think four days courses
black value is a bit longer
enters the exam with it in the course
so any questions so far is everybody
with me so far
okay so that's all i i wanted to just
give you a very closely overview of how
six sigma process works what is all
about
some examples
and this
examples are scattered throughout the
presentation
and i just want to do a little
quick summary now
let's look at the benefits of six sigma
so really
there's an issue there's a problem
there's a defects there's failures
so six sigma
helps us get into the root cause of
those failures those problems those
issues
and if you're creating a new product or
a service
six sigma helps you to create a defect
so that is
that is how this six sigma process works
so far
now what is in it
for you
as a professional
so why do you want to become why would
you want to become
a six sigma professional why would you
want to attend a course
go to exam go do some projects get a
certification
what is in it for you
just remember
once
you become a six sigma professional
you
have been armed with additional set of
tools which help you
improve the efficiency which help you
improve the bottom line
which help you improve the top line of
the organization of the business
it helps you increase the revenue of the
business
it helps you reduce the cost
in the business
whether it's manufacturing there is a
design
development
whether it is providing some service to
the customers
whatever it is whether it's a front desk
reception in hotel
whatever it is
you improve that service or the product
which is a great value
so there's only a few people
mostly in an organization which have
this
hills
and they moved around into the problem
areas
so it is a very valuable certification
and i call it a degree so if you become
a green belt it's like a degree a
college degree you become a black belt
from and you get the certification from
a reputed organization like simply learn
is
then you get an additional degree which
is available for any job you do
or any future job that you want to do
or any business that you want to
create
no matter where you are you apply the
skills
so i am i i'm not returning from
industry i have my own business
booking accounting and i apply this in
my business these concepts these tools
to do the business and in fact make my
life easier i mean
workload easy
here
so it is again it is
available
degree for you you become a valuable
much more business of that organization
so when you acquire this
degree certification
it's a very it's very very good
it's cool to have
so
that is the part of the six sigma moose
so any questions so far any questions
comments
from participants on the audience here
on this webinar
why don't i think i have a couple more
lights about
yeah sorry go ahead somebody said
something
i thought you were wrapping up so i'm
just going to say thank you that's
that's it but go go ahead and continue
yeah well
yeah thanks for seeing it and there's
only a couple more slides here
there's much more about simply learn
so i mean somehow you got to simply
learn and you signed up for this webinar
and there's
so the simply learn is quite a large
organization
it is
it's a global organization it's
mostly training
and it's trained over 100 000
professionals in many many branches
throughout the world
and you can see these dots of course
there's not enough dots here which is
such a small
view of the atlas
and of course on their website you can
do live chats you can find out
you can talk to them and
figure out whether something interests
you how the old brothers were
and they keep holding
revenue
stars
for all the professors a quick
overview of the different areas with the
training
so project management
big data finance
sap
software
microsoft i mean this is the microsoft
tools excel powerpoint those kind of
stuff
quality of isos and six sigma that
you're looking at and several ide and
again asia then
related to
software so there's
many many
and
what is in it
for you
so anyway i mean if you have any
questions and you think of any other
questions later on please feel free to
contact the simply learn
through the chat through the email
access they have shoot all your
questions your comments
and we will
do our best to answer them
so if there are no more
questions or comments
thank you everyone for attending this
thank you
i hope to see some of you thank you
thank you and hopefully
thank you
okay then
bye
oh
uh
okay
um
[Music]
oh